you
hi everyone is cherry I'm on Ches calm
and I got paired up playing now a 300
game how to seek out for 5 oh but 3o is
where we stand let's try clean B 3
playing against want to loose all right
let's go with a push or get on with
development
let's get on with development I do not
know this line Bishop g4 my queen is
going to be hit soon okay that's an
interesting maneuver it's probably all
theory here maybe a little bit fearful
of a night to be fix I think that's
where the knight is heading 'if I've I'm
planning to me with the d5 counsels you
know let's get them castles and on a
push
I guess the Knights still going to sink
into the d4 square maybe I could try to
challenge him right away okay but giving
up my light square bishop he's the worst
of the two now I think I like my
position even though they're playing
with the bishops and I try to undermine
my center still f5 is pretty sharp
f5 Bishop g5 9 to g5 there's f4 and take
this night and then maybe capture and
then look to take here but we first take
here I can't allow that push so now
suppose I just take this Knight and then
try to be greedy let's be greedy
I don't think Evelina I would end up in
a terrible pin because I have I have f4
and even if I have to give the pawn back
I think I'd be RI rook to e8 f4 so much
faster pace for sure two knights versus
two bishops but their King is also open
that's another big factor here so
eight or nine maybe queen 2d6 on Queen
d6 I think still I want to support my 90
pretty much have to do that my diagonals
weaken now and they're just piling up
let's put this right here
who check in with that rock I guess so
maybe I get a little bit crazy with g4f
five ideas but I still have to work out
this pin situation g5 would be pretty
sharp g5 maybe I would have a clean h5
okay so they're just going to try to
push yeah noted suppose I just hop right
on this diagonal clean here
now let's give this a try
nine to be five ideas might be there on
a queen move while this is with check so
yeah he's just going to go down isn't he
or should I still try to hang on to them
I went Knight to f3 and I'm not so quick
to get back the pond let's try it out
I have e1 supported enough tough game
probably sneak in a pre move you can't
go too far somewhere else where
giving check got this D six idea evening
out on the clock let's undo it what are
they thinking of here slow typer also my
Queens defending f4 just realizing that
now okay that's an interesting move
giving up that strong Bishop for what
reason I wonder that move huh well let's
jump in here now that there gave up the
dark square Bishop my knight should I
think at least increase in value still
defend a two I spin their Bishop is very
strong let's give him a boot
needs to reposition I think I want the
Queen's off don't know if I could really
take advantage of their King position
they have a check see five I guess I'm
going to be going to the corner soon and
they can win this pawn interesting okay
let's go here Queen exchange then my
knight has to find a new home I drop c4
I want this as my Hut okay they just
gave up this square I have Queen g5 this
is a really active post my clean now
where's the tactic feel like there
should be some tactic here let's start
with this and this and this I have a
check let's stay here controlling this
diagonal like my queen
host discoveries wits check I kept on
hunting isn't this a one King and pawn
and game we're going to find out King
their first down to the wire now it's
definitely winning right now they're
going to get there in time or are they
not quite I don't have enough time
that's three out for you yeah
game very very taiking for three oh
that's the only one i'm going to do but
as usual i like doing the five O's with
but ah yeah that's kind of what you get
with the three O's bit of a rat race to
finish I was forgetting that you could
do the multiple pre moves but yeah I was
interesting I definitely don't have too
much experience with this specific line
are really the white side against the
drunk felled yeah I don't know if they
treated this exactly how they're
supposed to Knight to Knight to c6 is
and I know I feel like he could he move
and c5 is an idea but the other the
other advance is the one they played in
the game a five you know I kind of have
to go with one of the two strikes to
challenge my center so knight on c6 I
guess II five is the way forward but
there's also some ideas - maybe circle
into the c-4 square
tonight repositioning to be six and 95
maybe Bishop to e6 as well
felt a kind of comfortable after this
decision to take my bishop I thought
that maybe this would be an idea and
then c6 I don't know because I thought
that mine my night was pretty good on on
f3 they had maybe something else at mine
oh here's maybe another thing maybe c5
is a move in this position and after
captures captures this Knight maybe goes
nowhere fast this is an idea to you know
try and reinforce the d4 square to have
the C pawn contributing or
I said that this is an idea but what I
really mean to say this is a common
concession that black will make
sometimes to have their queen side split
but the SI phan does a good job in
restricting this night fighting for
control over the d5 square it's an
interesting game interesting inbounds to
Knights rushes to bishops I had to save
her King but the same time I kind of
felt like I didn't or I couldn't really
take advantage of the fact that their
King was a little bit more vulnerable
even with the Queen still on the board
okay well let's uh dive in with the
analysis and see what more we could take
away from this one okay
let's dive in here and see if there are
any opening issues I don't think so
going to be three coming up g5 Queen to
b3 is just trying to force blacks hand
you take me
and they do they don't try to hang on to
the d5 point so chop-chop my queen is a
little bit uncomfortable still a lot of
pieces on board
the battle I have a center but a queen
that is vulnerable
castles p4
you have to try to show that this is a
an asset so you have to get these guys
going into c6 Bishop to e2 of these to
the bishop it stands better on e - to
not only secure the knight in the event
of Bishop g4 but this is a half-open
file for black so playing to d3 it'll be
a bit more vulnerable potentially the
default can open up and can have some
major pieces striking at the bishop on
d3 so yeah so right now it's pointing
out different stuff like Bishop f4
Bishop e3 committing the dark square
bishop
I don't think that took it really be
anything so around with Bishop to e2 and
now Knight to d7 so they were playing
the opening very fast so I imagine this
is some theory stuff I am NOT a up to
speed with and now huh look at that
there's already a tactic that both of us
missed here interesting there's a knight
takes d4 shot
that's really nice very very nice Knight
takes d4 Knight takes d4 and then a
knight move hitting my queen and it
suggests Knight - yeah I'd like to see
five staying out of the way now this
diagonal and they're going to be up upon
soon in just a moment gonzo hmm okay
yeah we both missed that tactical shot
that's good to know very nice so I
should be doing something different here
like Bishop to e3 yeah Bishop to e3 e5
are the top moves so this would make a
bit more sense right something that
would keep me from playing Bishop to e3
with the knight on f6 is Knight to g4
but hey he has different ideas so now
maybe I could already commit my Bishop
and this is this is very sensible it's
developing it's reinforcing the big d4
point where there is a lot of attention
so Bishop to e3
instead of Queen to d3 I'm not quite
sure why I reacted to you know I don't
know why committed my Queen at this
moment here I don't know I don't have
enhancer to that I guess I was just
anticipating the Knights going to go to
b6 so let's just go here right now but I
should probably wait to see if they're
even going to throw a punch of my queen
like that and continue to develop okay
just making mental notes to myself
Bishop to e3 much better and miss
tactical shot on d4 here Knight b6 right
here
d5 no I just went on with castles what
is going on d4 can be captured here -
what I guess we both experienced a
serious blind spot with d4 just basic
math here 3 is greater than 2
yeah I'm lacking a defender on d4
there's no kind of a fancy way to take
advantage of the pin I should say after
Knight takes here because this knight
can always make a capture with check at
minimum okay
giant blind spot on d4 for I guess both
of us g5
and I push d5 Bishop g5 s another one
d5 on 494 and now I played Bishop to e3
I express it to e3 next to d1 is another
one Knight takes on e 2 once I say
Knight takes Knight here hmm with then
maybe f5 yeah I don't know if I'm really
correct with this decision saying that
maybe tonight takes Knight is better
they are they are picking up a bishop
it's my bad Bishop but still still
Bishop and I don't know that you could
really maintain this night here c5 a
move I guess c5 is a move here d take C
B takes and as mentioned on does a good
job of cancelling out the knight splits
it's a bit split on the Queen side of
course but they get to keep this night
around for a little bit on two three
they have enough enough defense right
now and if I try to put some more
pressure on it well that that was a beep
on converted to see pawn and c5 would
hit once more so they could try to
simply maintain that strong post on D
form doing a lot of talking over the d4
square that's a that's the key square in
the grünfeld okay they gave up the night
and in this middle game I wonder what we
could have done a little bit different
a5 is really the break to go forward
with
I guess I was too fearful of this push
but I do have this as an option I want
to just throw a rock on the file or a
k2d one one of the rooks 2d one it's
suggesting of the two I'd probably go
with this one is the C file is pretty
pretty nice as well for the other room
so I could have held my ground and not
given up my center point so easily okay
I just captured because I was being
greedy right around this point I went
pawn hunting giving up the bishop for
Knight it's not a fan of that at the top
move but this is where okay now it's
showing up as one of the options Knight
to g5 wants to go with and also Bishop
takes Knight so chop chop pawn hunting
yeah Knight takes e5 and I have f4 if
black still has upon around this would
be an issue you know because of this pin
and then there's an ensuing move of d6
or f6 and my knight is cooked not the
case here so I get to take and now my
pawn is freed up to reinforce that night
in the event of a pin that's what they
go for
f4 I think it even popped up g5 for a
moment g5 it likes immediately hmm
to take advantage of that pin
mm that would have turned really sharp
g3 and now it's even saying here you fly
to g5 g3 ouch that scares me
yeah this g3 weakening light squares
around my own King have to be super
careful of weakening any color squares
around my King these bishops will snake
on in at some point okay
I think Oh g5 Queen d6 rook a to e1 it
likes
c6 okay I guess I'm just better here it
doesn't want to go a g4 this thought
that I had yeah maybe I even go in for
g4 it actually does like that move
once the what's the idea behind it after
Bishop to d7
I can't just continue to push this night
I have to be careful
I want to push and then play Queen to d2
this is tough to do especially that's
tough to go in a long game in
three-minute game it's that much more
difficult
yeah maybe if I was feeling crazy I
would do g4 but not now
okay now wants to go with g4 and there
seems to be a Wow seems to be winning
why I guess
I have some tactical idea it's a story
with g4g for Bishop d7 now and I have
something maybe here
oh-oh-oh we're kicking the we're taking
the bishop off of controlling the e4
square okay that would be the main point
to making this super committal g4
advanced oh my other concern okay so
even on this capture we're not we're not
doing this because we're in this pin but
even in this case we're getting in
Knight to e4 and as soon as the Queen
moves we have d6 so there was this idea
to try and push through with d6 that I
really did not pursue I only had it in
my mind there's maybe a knight to b5
move but I always felt that in the game
night to b5 can be met with Queen to c6
and that's check and that's going to
force the Queen's off but Knight to e4
on the other hand hits the Queen stops
this Queen trade India
that's a dagger and a half with d6 mmm
that would have been a nice spot
instead I went with something lame I was
too fixated on oh I'm going to lose upon
I don't have enough defense here so
let's run away scared that's what I did
and yeah I'm not sure why they gave up
the dark square Bishop but yes it's just
equal now even though I'm still up upon
and so that's one of the moves this
capture on c3 I took with the pawn
because I still wanted to defend this
guy now Bishop to e4 and it feels like
they're getting that pawn back but I
definitely do like my knight I miss e5
square also that's something equal but
anything can happen in this position
still so imbalanced minor piece wise and
King safety wise they have I don't know
if we could even call the bishop the
superior minor piece because he has a
great say in this position from a5
and black has the weakened King post
clean c5 yo s trying to hang on to a to
what other move to a half for the Queen
I'd I didn't like Queen to d4 because
they're going to grab my a to pawn
saying something like this I definitely
just as it was in the game I didn't want
to take their queen because then they
take over control this key to e5 square
so they want to play it where I give up
the a pawn and then just kind of
relocate relocate the Queen over here on
f2
okay well I just want to defend directly
a to to f8 and would I do c4 c4 Bishop
to e6 and I'm just trying to regroup
here my Queens out of play
wouldn't mind a queen exchange here yeah
I've kind of given up on this idea to
maybe attack their king they have a lot
of pieces around and mmm just have to
get in another to tie in another piece
let's say with the knight on e5 I mean
when they play g5 on I wouldn't be
surprised if there's something then for
me so getting in these little baby moves
this is my Hut now for my King g5 is
probably a bit too crazy Queen h5 it
does like and after captures maybe I
have something here now
no tactic missed yet clean g5 King h8
just pick up the pawn may be here
there's something I have anything good
here oh that's interesting now it's a
pretty cool tactic and the rook and pawn
endgame and now you end up with a super
active rook I have Knight to g6 clean
exchange and then take here so right now
materials even but I will be picking up
a pond and they are just all lined up
they may all fall
oh if I would have thought just a hair
more just a hair more here but
it felt like there was something right
around this point as soon as my queen
snuck in and then there was this cheque
capture capture right here is where I
sensed there would be something that's a
cool one I like that combo very nice
I just wanted to defend Queen to III and
yeah maybe there was another tactic
missed the ending the King and pawn
endgame was winning Knight takes g6 here
is what I played yeah okay because this
is I could just trade all the way down a
different move order though a different
move order they takes g6 with then Queen
to h6 oh I'm actually winning the pawn I
could take here the Queen can take she
has a responsibility after pawn takes I
have Queen to h6 and okay so I could
take the rook and then take the pawn I
can't take right away I thought I could
take right away but here here computer
will go for this move so it's not quite
a forced you know I can't quite for say
strictly King and pawn endgame King h8
and now yeah okay but I think the other
variation is maybe just winning as well
I think I could force the Queen's off
because after this Queen of d4 is and
isn't this strong it's not well it's not
going to force off the Queen's because
he could just slide step that hmm okay
so there wasn't a clear way to force off
the Queen's there a variation to pick up
this pond and have the Queen's off which
is awesome and everything but to to make
it super clean I would like to somehow
find a way to force the Queen's off here
so I was a bit surprised to see this
move because this is an unhealthy group
of three versus two and they can't by
force whoops
they cannot by force create a passed
pawn without investing a a pawn I
believe like so so PO
we just shuffle for a moment I go King
f1 and if they ever go here I'm just
making dummy moves to illustrate
captures captures if this ends up and
that's how it was in the game this one
pawn will stop boat they could however
force through oh no it's actually it's
not even guaranteed that they could
force through a pasta passed pawn and
and do they don't have to give up a pawn
to create a passed pawn I don't I don't
think that they could even manage that
much where they can force a passed pawn
by giving up a pawn because the way to
do that would be to play C five and then
play B five however as soon as C five is
played I have this move a four and these
two offset and this a pawn controls
these two now in the game I didn't see
it as once we got to this point I just
felt that it was winning because I
thought you know this is not going to be
a you know this isn't a healthy
structure that can successfully create a
passed pawn on the Queen side but I
looking at it closely it is a it is the
case that it is it is in fact not a good
structure to work with many many times
having split pawns like this can be very
effective in preventing a completely
healthy group of a completely healthy
group of three pawns so yeah but this
this should be just winning I'm
surprised it's just saying a pawn and a
half advantage maybe you just have to
give it a little bit of time felt like
right around this point you just
centralize the King and kind of golden
and seems to just be a winning advantage
let's go with h4 but I figured might as
well race up
to the center first and was there
anything lost here in this King and pawn
and game let's see I think I hold the
only the only other note here is that I
don't want to play g4 first because now
black plays g5 and one pawn restricts
too so there's this idea this is known
as the candidate pawn so he should be
moved first he should be the leader
Candida pond is the one that is not
obstructed by any opposing ponds that
are on the same file so as a rule he
should move first h4 and I will be able
to get in g4 and just scoop my king over
for a moment and they're trying to get a
passed pawn but it's not really going to
work out g4 and this is just winning you
know I could just take even suggested c5
as a move but isn't this winning as well
it is push and yeah this is just working
out I guess the only other detail is
well of course I'm going to take this
pawn first but yeah I would want to take
this pawn first if there's somehow a
situation where and I'm not sure how to
say it exactly but I want I would like
to take this one first and then move up
here because my king wants to play the
like a shouldering off type of role so
that the the black king can't get in
into the corner to stop my rook pawn so
this is just winning but
time to pull it off interesting game
though and some interesting points in
that
middlegame with the d4 square we were
blind
both of us were blind on many occasions
but anyhow feel free as usual to leave
any feedback to this a typical 300 time
control game I hope you're having a
great day and I will catch you soon
that's all for now
take care